[موسيقى]
تواصلت أوبك مع بعض
نظرائها من خارج الأوبك مثل روسيا لقطع
1.8 مليون برميل يوميًا من السوق ،
لكن لم يكن هناك سوى
استجابة باهتة مما أثار التساؤل حول ما إذا كانت أوبك
لا تزال ذات صلة ، فهذه
اتفاقية تاريخية حقًا لم تفعل ذلك أبدًا
كانت موجودة قبل أن يكون هناك قدر كبير من
عدم الثقة ، وبالتالي عادت أوبك بالتأكيد مع شركائها هذه الدول غير الأعضاء في الأوبك ،
فهي قوة رئيسية في
سوق النفط العالمية ولكنها ليست القوة الوحيدة
التي تشاركها قاعدتها مع منتجي النفط الصخري
وهو أمر جديد تمامًا  اللعبة وفي
الواقع في الآونة الأخيرة مع الأسواق المالية
التي لها تأثير متزايد بشكل متزايد
على ما يحدث
لسعر النفط والاتجاه الكامل لسوق النفط
بشكل جيد ، لا يزال لدى أوبك
تأثير كبير جدًا على السوق
ولكنها ليست الوحيدة  المنتجون بأي
وسيلة ولا يوجد جميع
أعضاء أوبك بالضرورة في نفس
الموقف ، لذلك أعتقد أنه لا يزال لديهم
تأثير كبير على أن أوبك
ستكون دائمًا ذات صلة  ستكون قوة
أعتقد أن أحد الأشياء أن هناك عرضًا
أوسع مما كان عليه
قبل 15-20 عامًا ، وهذا العرض الأوسع
يجلب المزيد من الأصوات وكتأثير ،
لكنني لن أقلل أبدًا من
أهمية الانفتاح لأنني أعتقد أن أوبك
هي  لا يزال بعض أهم
المنتجين في العالم يزودونهم
ارتباطًا
وثيقًا بمنحنى العرض وأعتقد أن الصوت لا يزال
صوتًا قويًا للغاية